hey Vsauce Michael here
leave your entry zeroes before this
video begins I don't know if I told you
guys about my chair only 399 I don't
know it also if you're aware of this but
it can do Oh shame Leslie plug in your
mean merch Felix Wow Wow random applause
for me everybody yes I do want to pay
for an outdated meme Felix thank you
finally for answering this hey listen up
you slimy scumbag this orange t-shirt is
fire clearly it is so tight man oh boy
hey look at that face huh can you do
that face we spent hours perfecting this
art okay we spent years that's why it
took so long oh yeah
but can you do this
enough enough plugging your merch Felix
who are you logan paul let's review the
memes from last week we had some amazing
stuff I've been sneak peeking a little
bit
very very quality hey can i copy your
homework
that's my Irish accent by the way sure
just change a few things so it's not
obvious okay top foot up on into you I
did a little meme here that Jack were
the exact same attire for his TV
presentation you know I'm proud I'm
proud of my my boy
but you straight up stole my outfit Jack
and you know it so I like handedly try
and hand this to him but of course jack
has to make a comment about my handshake
disability and I gotta tell you I'm
really disappointed in Jack me and the
handshake disability community are
strong okay and we're stronger than you
and your hatred so next time you make
fun of anyone for not being a mistakes
maybe you should think do you smoke
every time I die in a video game your
lungs are in perfect health
of course
this meat was made by Sir Nicky it's got
an amazing channel you guys should check
it out I've seen this one
great job repos okay and then the final
stage can be the shirt the most valuable
photo company sells no cameras the
largest network lace no cables the
largest accommodator provider owns no
real estate the largest and most
subscribed youtube channel creates no
content on own they figured me out
seven things they finally learned my
secret dad damn it the hell is this oh
[Laughter]
hell yeah miss me with that price 399
baby it just keeps going my cut
hey hey come come on come come no spells
all right I gotta upload that derp Chris
well done
what is this upload so Pete if I could
see this yeah gotcha
hey guys don't make fun of the Minecraft
Pig okay he has feelings too please a
part of you or worse that's great sir
you've been in a coma since 2000 it's
2018 now what games do gamers play now
sir Dooku that's right guys anyone can
be a gamer you can just play Sudoku on
your phone and you can still be an epic
gamer dude just like myself 398 got
today's video it was only seven minutes
so what did you do about it I didn't do
anything
whoa well Brad Brad knows he knows that
there will be consequences if the video
doesn't hit ten minutes that he doesn't
even want to get into that he would even
dare to get into touch
this is Brad and supposed to be my our
site got another video see I mentioned
Cyprus well you're welcome shape God
another video to edit should be easy
it's from Peter Pan let's see it's four
minutes long
come on you can you can ease please
stretch that out come
what's with it ten minutes means come on
makes actual good content worth ten
minutes puts in intros and outros to
puts in intros and outros to well if you
gotta make a meme at least [ __ ] help
put in intros and outros to extend the
video to ten minutes calls out other
youtubers to make a ten minute video
costs after every 10 excuse me
seconds to make chick made flat earthers
Wow another solid evidence for the Flat
Earth community your move
Neil the [ __ ] theis I made this at
school hope you will you like it oh my
god and I'm wearing the shirt now yeah
unlike he gave me the plug guys that are
almost like popping out that's amazing
but as eyes can see the future my dad in
Vietnam 1971 didn't know this photo
existed until I came across randomly on
the internet he cried when he saw it
hope this is the right place to post
be smashed sixty oh I haven't seen that
son-of-a-bitch facing yes everyone is
like can you bring back Beastmaster yeah
I'll bring back Beastmaster when pokemon
go is popular again what do you what do
you think I'm gonna do what in the world
am I looking at how youtubers gets their
ideas is asked question and answers them
ask questions and fans answered them
waits for jacksFilms to upload it's not
true he copied me
everyone knows that moving on this
drawing has taken 84 years I hope you
like it
I absolutely love it it is 10 out of 10
I just traced a screen from a video stop
up I think the the awfulness of it
actually makes it look good so props to
you Burger King felt ladders like if you
cried guys please like if we cried it on
this video and by the merch if you
didn't
remember the burger boy from Salva this
is him now feel old you know man
that's it normally we just edit that out
but I know but I know my editors are so
wonderful and nice that they will make
me look as good as possible any scenario
and if something disgusting happens that
I don't want to be shown they would do
the gym they would do me justice and cut
it out oh that's sick wait wait for him
to jump out of the closet you merely
adopted the closet I was born in the
closet clearly only Marzia knows how to
model a hat
why do you have to bully me all the time
find enough videos to make you laugh you
lose
long enough repeat the same video at
least three times what what are you
talking about listen do you know how
hard it is to find videos aren't
copyrighted that won't claim my video
after a weeks I lose all revenue to you
know my pain do you know my suffering
then now I will repeat the video three
times four times if necessary mini
crossbow shooting targets how do we know
you're not a giant
[Music]
what is this
oh my stop compiling my bad handshakes
please mom can I hang out with my
friends tonight yeah as long as you
bring your brother I hope you like it
please give it up bub that's dope
I want those glasses when there is no
bonus meme that's right
truly the saddest moment of the week is
when there is no bonus mean waiting
around the corner I understand nice
chair I love the background it's so
detail and well drawn incredible it
looks it looks photorealistic well done
I'm kidding great job sir junkman very
nice my fears learning Ted 1001 I've
never been so proud I think he even
mentioned it to me because she noticed
that he was and she was like my video
was 1001 getting a picture of Peter pie
every day until eats a picture of me I'm
not gonna eat a picture of you just stop
ok it's not happening alright leave a
like if you enjoyed watching cop that
merge cop that chair do whatever you
want I don't care glue that right squad
for me